aquí dibujé un círculo con radio r y con
centro en el punto h acá es decir si
bajó para acá llegó llegó a h y si me
voy hacia la izquierda llegó a una
altura acá lo que quiero hacer en este
vídeo es encontrar una fórmula general
para una ecuación que cumplan todos los
puntos que están sobre la orilla del
círculo y recordemos que esos puntos
justos son aquellos puntos que están a
distancia r del centro del círculo vale
bueno entonces lo que queremos hacer es
ver qué restricciones cumplen o cumple
un punto x ya que está sobre el círculo
para que de adeveras su distancia al
centro sea igual a r entonces déjame
tomar un punto el que sea sobre sobre la
orilla del círculo sobre la
circunferencia le voy a poner punto x
coma ya lo estoy poniendo de este lado
pero puede estar por acá por acá o por
acá vale bueno entonces este punto x
coma que tiene que cumplir que tiene qué
relación existe entre xy hk y r
para que este punto realmente esté sobre
la circunferencia bueno pues de alguna
forma tenemos que decir que está
distancia siempre es r y para eso vamos
a utilizar el teorema de pitágoras de
una manera muy ingeniosa voy a construir
un triángulo rectángulo como sigue
de aquí de este punto voy a trazar un
segmento paralelo al eje y voy a ir
hacia abajo y de este punto de acá del
centro de la circunferencia voy a trazar
un segmento paralelo al eje x me voy a
ir para acá y esos segmentos se
intersectan en un cierto punto que está
aquí ahora como los ejes son
perpendiculares y estos segmentos son
paralelos a los ejes entonces este
ángulo de acá va a ser de 90 grados y
justo este es el triángulo al cual le
vamos a aplicar el teorema de pitágoras
va bueno en este triángulo ya conocemos
la hipotenusa falta conocer la longitud
de los otros dos lados de los catetos
pero está también la podemos calcular en
términos de xy h&k esas longitudes cómo
le hacemos pues por ejemplo qué hacemos
con este lado notamos que que si nos
vamos hacia acá si nos vamos hacia la
izquierda llegamos a una altura y por lo
tanto la longitud de este segmento es de
menos acá lo voy a poner aquí
- voy a usar colores - acá entonces ahí
tenemos la longitud de este segmento y
de manera similar si bajamos si bajamos
perpendicularmente al eje x entonces
aquí tenemos que se llega al punto x
verdad al valor x y por lo tanto la
longitud de este segmento es x menos h
menos h
aquí ya quedó un poquito encimado pero
ni modo bueno y con esto ya conocemos
las longitudes de estos dos lados y por
lo tanto podemos aplicar el teorema de
pitágoras a este triángulo lo voy a
escribir de este lado en color verde voy
a escribir lo correspondiente a x menos
h entonces nos quedaría que x menos h x
menos h elevado al cuadrado más y voy a
poner en otro color en color naranja lo
correspondiente a este más ye menos k
más o menos acá elevado al cuadrado es
igual a r elevado al cuadrado a r
elevado al cuadrado vale r es la
hipotenusa porque es el ángulo es el
lado opuesto al ángulo de 90 grados y
listo ya tenemos nuestra nuestra
ecuación para un círculo esto es lo que
tienen que cumplir los puntos x g para
que estén en el círculo de centro h
comarca y radio radio igual a r vale
esto está padrísimo y de y bueno también
cualquier pareja que satisfaga está
sobre el círculo o sea las que están
satisfacen y las que satisfacen están
eso está bueno vamos a hacer un pequeño
ejemplo imagínate que queremos encontrar
la ecuación del círculo con centro le
voy a poner por acá con centro
centro en el punto 5 - 5 desde el centro
y que tenga radio
radio nos digamos igual a 4 radio 4
bueno pues entonces simplemente tenemos
que identificar quiénes son
hk y r vale aquí tenemos que que 5 es
igual a h lo voy a poner en colores esto
ya caixa h estoy acá es k
estoy acá es acá lo estoy poniendo muy
chiquito pero bueno y el radio es 4 esté
acá este de acá sería r entonces
simplemente sustituimos la ecuación nos
quedaría lo siguiente nos quedaría nos
quedaría x menos 5 menos 5 elevado al
cuadrado elevado no voy a poner en color
verde elevado al cuadrado más y aquí va
lo correspondiente ayer más y menos -5
entonces sería más 5 + 5 en color rosa
elevado al cuadrado elevado al cuadrado
al cuadrado es igual a 4 elevado al
cuadrado es decir es igual a 16 a 16
entonces estaré acá sería la ecuación
para la circunferencia concentró en
menos 5 en perdón en 5 menos 55 menos 5
y radio igual a 4 y también se puede
pensar al revés si nos dan la ecuación
podemos identificar
y el radio de la circunferencia
simplemente tenemos tenemos que pensar
que estamos restando esto entonces esa
sería la primera entrada verdad es decir
el centro tendría primera entrada igual
a 5 porque estamos restando 5 y segunda
entrada igual a menos 5 porque hacer más
5 es restar menos menos 50 un poco
confuso pero se puede pensar un poco más
fácil sí sí sí sí vemos cuál es el valor
de x que hace que esto sea igual a cero
sería x igual a 5 esta es la primera
entrada y el valor que hace que esto sea
igual a 0 el valor de g
es menos 5 sería la segunda entrada vale
bueno entonces ahí tenemos cómo
encontrar la ecuación de un círculo y
notemos que si el círculo está centrado
en el origen entonces h y cada sería
igual a 0 y simplemente nos quedaría x
al cuadrado más ye al cuadrado es igual
a r al cuadrado